- Journée radieuse à Lviv.
Journée presque normale pour
célébrer le plus beau cadeau
de la vie : une naissance.
Laurence Couture Gagnon
e ces moments trop rares
en Ukraine avec son petit Léo
né il y a deux semaines.
Il pesait quatre livres.
LAURENCE COUTURE GAGNON
- On l'a nommé Léo parce qu'ici,
bien, le nom de la ville,
c'était Léopolis avant.
Puis, on pense qu'il a vraiment
voulu naître ici. Puis, mongran.
- Ils avaient fui Kiev avec
l'idée de se rendre en Pologne.
L'accouchement en temps de
guerre dans l'hôpital presque
entièrement déserté de Lviv
n'aurait pas pu mieux se passer.
- Ils nous ont mis même
au premier étage. Il y avait
un peu de protection.
Donc, ils voulaient pas qu'on
soit dans les étages, 4e étage,
3e étage, s'il y avait
des bombardements.
Mais le personnel était calme.
Le médecin aussi.
- À Mykolaïv,
théâtre de violents combats
et bombardements dans le sud
de l'Ukraine, chaque naissance
est un petit miracle.
Le sous-sol de l'hôpital
a été aménagé en refuge.Les acct
malgré les sirènes d'alarme.
Quelques heures après
la naissance de son petit
garçon, Alina se porte bien.
Elle espère qu'il n'y aura pas
trop d'alarmes, car elle a peur
que son bébé tombe malade.
Il fait froid dans le sous
Risques énormes, certaines
interventions doivent quand mê
être pratiquées en salle
d'opération, au premier étage.
- Loin du danger, le passage
de Laurence à Lviv se prolonge.t
un document de voyage canadien
pour Léo afin d'aller
se réfugier en Pologne.
Elle vient cependant d'obtenirue
ukrainien après deux semaines
et elle pourra partir.
- Bien, nous, on avait notre
plan d'habiter en Ukraine où
on a un emploi, donc on espère
revenir. On a notre appartement,
sa chambre de bébé,
nos amis, notre réseau social,
notre clinique. Kiev, c'est une
ville qui est super agréable.
- La résilience prend toutes
sortes de formes en Ukraine.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radioviv.viv.viv.viv.viv.viv.